- Good morning believe nation!
Today's message is stay focused.
Over to you Victoria Beckham.
(rooster crow)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- When I initially started up the brand,
I didn't put too much pressure on myself,
I didn't go into this to
prove anything to anybody
other than myself.
I was very focused, I didn't
try to do everything at once.
For quite a few seasons I
stuck to just perfecting
the dress, I didn't want
to run before I could walk.
It's very important to be
focused and do what I was doing
very, very well and move on
and do more, when my team
was in the position to do that.
So I think that it's about
keeping things focused
and not trying to do too much.
- I think this is one
of the things that sinks
tons of entrepreneurs.
So many entrepreneurs that I
know are the creative types,
right, creative geniuses, amazing.
And you have this idea, I
love this idea, this is great,
what an amazing idea, and then
you're off running with it,
and then poof you meet somebody
or some other idea comes
to you and then forget this,
I'm going to go over here now,
and you start working on this
thing and then poof you want
to go this way now.
You're off on some totally
new thing, and you're sitting
around with 25 different
projects sitting at 50% done,
and nothing ever gets to completion.
That's so many entrepreneurs
because you can't focus on
one thing at a time, and if
you are that to the extreme,
if you can only be the
idea generation person,
and you just can never get
yourself focused, then my
advice to you isn't force
yourself to be focused because
you're not going to thrive,
but find somebody to help
finish these projects.
Get it to the point where
you're making some money
with it and somebody can
help partner with you,
who is the super
operations, detail oriented,
focused person, to help
get you through because
otherwise you're just
going to be sitting there
on a pile of projects
that never get completed.
And you're never going to
have the impact of success
you want as a entrepreneur.
I'm fortunate enough to have
both, I can be the creative
and the visionary and go and
do big things, and come up with
new ideas that haven't happened
before, but I also like
finishing stuff.
I like having commitments,
I like scheduling things in,
and keeping to my schedule.
What I find the balance
that I strike is most days
I wake up and I follow my schedule.
Things have to happen every
week, and this is the schedule
that I follow.
Wednesday is my video recording day, I'm
coming to the studio
and I'm filming videos.
But then on the days that
come where there's some
crazy idea, I'll go for it,
I'll start it, I'll work
on it to the expense
of everything else on my schedule.
I'll move meetings, I'll
switch video day around
because when I can get into
that zone, I can create
some amazing stuff.
But that's not every day,
I don't wake up every day
in the zone, really working
on some new creative idea.
So I find that that balance
really works for me.
What I've done, is I always
start a project myself.
Myself, my energy, my time,
my hustle, my drive, and
then as it builds up I
either get it to the point
where I can afford to
bring on a team to help me
because it's making some money,
or I don't, and I drop it.
I kill off more projects
than most people start.
When I started this YouTube
channel is a great example.
I had a successful business,
I had a website, I still
have a website, I have a
team of people on my website,
I decided I'm going to
start a YouTube channel.
I could've taken money from
that business to start the
channel, to buy the basics,
to buy the gear, and all that
stuff, I started with
zero dollars doing it,
just my time, borrowed
gear, borrowed equipment,
I did the editing, I
did the research, I was
in front of the camera, I did everything.
I kept my team doing what
they were doing, building that
business while I went off
and did this crazy thing
on YouTube.
Now luckily it worked, and
I built it up and now I've
built a YouTube team around
it, but a lot of those
projects that I'll work on
my own, they don't take off.
Most of it is because I
don't, I lose my excitement
for it, like YouTube could
have been, I made five videos
and then like you know what,
that was a good try, I'm like
I'm glad I gave it a shot,
it's just I don't enjoy it
I'm not going to do it, and I cut out.
And so I think it's super
important that you understand
the personality type that
you are, you have that
self awareness to say,
either I can be more focused
and I need to pick the project
that I'm going to work on,
right?
This is something I'm doing
with trying to dance salsa.
This business right here, and
Alex, I gave him ten options
when we sat down.
Here are the ten ways we
can grow our business.
Ten different ways, we
can't do all of them because
if we try to do all of
them, we're going to suck
at everything, we're going
to have a whole bunch of
50% projects.
This one we have to do, you
pick one of the other nine.
He picked one, and every time
it's tempting to come back
and say oooh, ooh here's an idea.
I saw this video that somebody
put out, what if we did
like this thing way over here, no, focus!
Forget that, yes it can work,
but it has to be done well.
Focus, these two things, that's
what we're doing, that's it.
Don't worry about anything
else, and if you don't have
the discipline to put that
on yourself, and it's not the
skill set that you want
to build and develop then
you need to have somebody
come on and help you.
You need to have somebody
that you can hand projects
off to and they can run with it.
And you can take it far
enough to get to the point
where you can make some money with it,
and they can run with it and
help you build the business,
while you move onto the next
project, then the next project,
and the next project.
You need to have that skill
somewhere in your arsenal,
either you develop it
yourself or you bring somebody
on to help you, otherwise
you're not going to have
success as an entrepreneur.
So the question of the day
today is, are you focused
enough at finishing the
projects that you start?
Leave in the comments below I'm going
to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shoutout to Steve Saunders from
stevesaunders.info.
Steve, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book.
Your One Word, I really,
really, really appreciate it.
Thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word
is and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for
another shot of entpresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- So as a special bonus
for you guys, I'm adding
some extra clips around
staying focused that I hope
you will enjoy and will help.
- How do you prepare
yourself to be so focused,
to handle all this massive stress?
- Really it's trying
to just remain focused
on the job at hand and then the task.
My goal this weekend is to win this race.
All the other stuff is all just
noise, and I guess it's just
through experience being
able to silence all that
and stay focused on what's
the most important thing.
So don't be distracted by
all the media, all the camers
tomorrow there's so many
interviews, mostly with
the same people that we always
have, so I've been talking
to these guys for ten
years, but are often asking
the same question that
they ask me two weeks ago.
But obviously they have
something more to talk
about this weekend because
the last race was terrible.
But I think really it's
trying to compartmentalize
really that stuff put over
here, put it in a box, and then
keep the energy and your
focus on the one thing
that matters most.
All of that other stuff does
not matter, what matters is
me and this team, how are
we going to get from Friday,
or Thursday this week
for example, to Sunday
standing on top of that podium.
It's sleep, it's what I eat,
it's what I spend my time
doing, making sure I get to bed early.
All these different
things that add up to it.
And sometimes you do it all
perfect, and it doesn't go well,
but that's life, and you just
hope that in doing all the
right things, but it's also
trying to find a balance,
you need to enjoy life as well.
At some stage I'm going,
my career will be over, and
I want to look back and say
I enjoyed absolutely everything,
every moment in the car,
every moment out of it.
- Well when you're doing a tv
show, every day is a different
day in the sense that it's never the same.
And you might be shooting
two scenes, you might have
one scene, you might have
five scenes, so your level
of preparation is different every time.
Generally I'm up early, I
exercise, I run, I do whatever
it is I'm doing in terms
of my physical life other
than playing tennis, which
I stack up during the
course of a week, quite
a lot of, if I can.
And get to set, depending
on your call time but
very often it's very early.
And then you try to be
there and be alert and awake
and alive and ready to
go every hour of the day.
And if you work twelve
hours then you have to be
alert every one of those hours.
It's an important thing to stay focused.
- It wasn't conscious on my
part to have another script
sort of ready to go by the
time we went to film festivals
with Following, while we were
finishing up the cut on it
and doing very long,
slow technical finishing,
which when you have no money
it takes forever because
you're still waiting for
the lab to run the 16mm bath
or whatever it is, in that
time I was putting together
a script for Memento so also
in the time it took to get
Following noticed on the
festival circuit so we could
get out there, I had
actually finished the script.
In retrospect, it was a
massive advantage because I was
able to say okay you like
that film, this is what I want
to do next because in your
best case scenario of what
can happen to you with putting
a film out there and getting
distribution for example, you
are then asked the question
okay what do you want to do
next, and if you have an answer
you can use that very short
window of interest that you
get from people in what you've done.
But I will say that I think
that was purely an accident,
and I think that if you were
to try and plan to write
another script while
you are finishing a film
you really risk taking
your focus off the project
that you're doing.
And I think that it's most
important to just throw yourself
into just putting everything
into the project you're working
on and that's something
I've always done since.
If you can then because
quite often there is a period
between finishing a project
and actually people seeing it
or actually people responding to it.
If you can try instead of going
on holiday for six months,
you can use that period
to try and figure out what
you would do next if someone
gave you the opportunity.
Then you're going to give
yourself a huge advantage.
- Obstacles really don't matter.
They really just don't, no
more than where you come from,
what you had, what you
have, what you didn't have,
all that stuff becomes so what.
People that are concerned
with results and the person that's working
with their mind fixed on the
end result of being success
are a lot less concerned
about the problems
and they're more willing
to explore solutions,
and if need be, create them.
That is probably the
best use of your energy.
Arnold Schwarzenegger was said
to have once give a seminar
somewhere, I think they
referenced it in the, either
the book The Education Of A
Bodybuilder or the encyclopedia
Arnold Schwarzenegger's
Encyclopeica of Bodybuilding,
one time giving a seminar it
was said that he talked about
focusing on his goal and
how the only time you can
begin to really assess the
enormity of an obstacle was
to have to first take
your eye off your goal.
That's the end of my Arnold
Schwarzenegger quote.
But I guess in recalling
that at this moment,
what I realize is if I'm
a NFL outside linebacker
looking to try to put a
sack on the quarterback
of the opposing team,
if I am looking at the size
of the lineman in front of me,
looking to stop me, the
defenders looking to stop me,
from getting to the quarterback,
if I start taking into
account, wow, how big is
his hands, and how much does
this guy weigh, and man,
look at the size of his neck,
chances are in order to make
all of those assessments,
I can't be looking at the
quarterback behind him anymore.
And if my responsibility in
this play, was to put pressure
on the quarterback and even
better, put my hands on the
quarterback, cause a fumble
or stop the play, then I'm
going to be rendered
ineffective, not by anything the
lineman has done, but because
I have now taken my eye
off the goal in order to
assess the size and weight
of the obstacle in front of me.
Successful people I imagine
have to worry less about
what the size of the obstacles
are, the finances or the
lack thereof and all the
other things that we can say
represent the size and the
weight of the opposition,
and what the successful
person is going to aim to do,
what all of us would like to
be successful would probably
want to adopt as part of
our philosophy, would be
to worry less about the obstacles
and fix our thoughts on the goal.